freunde herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video ihr habt dem titel gelesen
luxus försters klassiker das hatten wir
schon mal mit verschiedenen gerichten
heute machen wir das in der sommerlichen
grille die ziehen hier vor mir stehen
schon zwei verschiedene bratwürste oder
sorten von bratwurst einmal hier der
marktführer ihr kennt sie vielleicht dem
brutzeln okay war sehr schön und hier
drinnen habe ich eine ibérico bratwurst
ihr werdet heute feststellen wir haben
zum einen so die gängigen produkte ich
habe trotzdem eine gute qualität gekauft
also keine gewissem sinne also was
vernünftig ist ein guter standard
trotzdem auf dem supermarkt und die
anderen sachen sind alle vom metzger vom
feinkosthändler und ibérico ist wie zum
beispiel bei den rindern die walküre ist
ibérico etwas ganz besonders feines wir
testen heute lohnt es sich diesen
unterschied zu machen wenn ich werde
euch dann auch immer sagen wie es sich
preislich unterscheidet das ganze aber
wir legen erstmal die ersten würste auch
hier sieht man noch so dieses klassische
der mitte so obendrauf kraft wenn am
rathaus ist ja eigentlich was relativ
simples was ja auch durch die
einfachheit heute ich überzeugt wie sehr
lohnt es sich da was von ibérico schwein
das ist ganz normal im rathaus zu gehen
das ist nicht irgendein grill hat es
gesehen habe major upgrade gemacht aber
nur ein partner auf einem schein
bernhard die haben mir freundlicherweise
diesen wunderbaren grill zugeschickt das
ist ein brett deluxe und er ist wirklich
die luchse wir werden heute in seiner
ganzen pracht benutzen das wird viel
spaß mache ich später noch dazu merkt
deshalb seht ihr auch einfach mal
vielleicht werbung eingeblendet aber wir
legen erstmal die bratwürste auch
mittlere hitze ich habe heute auch sehr
versierte kaum zu besuchen nämlich randy
und lukas nebst natürlich eric lahrer
jakob also heute ist richtig barbecue
party angesagt ihr werdet nicht nur auf
meine meinung vertrauen müssen sondern
wenn euch ein bisschen was anderen
bratwurst grillen ist ungefähr so
interessant zu erzählen wie pesto machen
oder zwiebeln steinen deshalb würde ich
sagen ein bisschen wie roll und dann
sehen wir uns wenn die gleich
[Musik]
wir haben unsere bist du schön winslow
goldbraun gegrillt also liebe ich
wirklich gesehen hier schon so leicht
aber dieses auf geplant dass es so 26 6
das können wir jetzt auch perfekte so ne
currywurst war ja am anleger war also
hier erstmal unsere luxusvariante hier
so der marktführer der klassiker haben
wir so einen tag statt aber das mag ich
sehr gerne einmal so den kontrasten
business play war zehn euro drei euro
fünfzig wer gewinnt den geschmackstest
[Musik]
wie gesagt haben ja auch gäste hier
neben mir jetzt lukas und rechts von mir
ich sei es geht ich habe etwas gedreht
sondern eine von vielen sachen und wir
probieren gemeinsam könnte ich meine
gabel ich sage euch gar nicht was das
ist vielleicht könnte ich denke
vielleicht nicht ich habe ja schon
gesagt es gibt eine luxusversion ein
klassiker
kommt fangen wir alle gemeinsam mit der
angehen wir uns davon den gelblichen ich
weiß natürlich schon was das ist jung
zwar nicht probleme
also mein erster eindruck es ist auf
jeden fall egal was im spektrum
bratwurst nein so was ist nicht so als
würde irgendwas ganz verrücktes
passieren können sie aber sehr sehr gut
da ich auch schön cremig und auch so
eine kürzung oder so eine tiefe
salzgehalt stimmt nur vielleicht hätte
ein bisschen besser gewählt sein können
[Musik]
denn hier bald werden wollte lukas mich
sehr kritisch bewertet eine folge
persönlicher koch ist auf dem weg was
sagst du mich sehr lecker auch sehr
cremig ich breche nicht viel auszusetzen
wenn ich ehrlich bin schweres los
[Musik]
ganz anders mehr jetzt bin ich gespannt
ja also solche mehr bist kann es anders
ja ich weiß die fühlt sich einfach auch
anders wäre die besser gegrillt also die
waren gleichzeitig drauf oder ja ja ja
du bist und auch ich finde ein bisschen
schönere geschmack irgendwie schon wenn
ich ehrlich bin also ich finde als
gehalt von der textur ja wie hier ist
wirklich schön cremig die hatten
deutlich stärken bist und ich finde auch
so die wurst haut hat nicht so einen
schönen text vorgetragen habe ich jetzt
gesagt so eine sache gibt es dieses bis
hin zu salzig aber ich bin trotzdem sehr
die sagen das stimmt ich weiß ja was was
ist und für mich war es wirklich so ich
glaube es eine ganz klare frage von dem
was man lieber hat es gibt tage da
wächst bei der jetzt gerade hat mir die
besser geschmeckt aber wir haben noch
einiges vor so der grill ist jetzt auf
350 grad grad haben wir alles lohnt slow
gemacht und no job ich grill zum ersten
mal trat damit und ich muss wirklich
sagen das ist ein dickes upgrade weil
wir haben eine absolute vielseitigkeit
wir haben 2 staab brenner mit dem man
hier so ganz klassisch einfach die hitze
unter dem rost regulieren kann wir haben
einen keramik brenner mit 900 grad oder
bis zu 900 grad hitze machen wir gleich
unsere schön wagners 6 unter anderen und
wir haben da drüben sogar noch eine
kleine portionen kleines kochfeld also
es ist sehr vielseitig ihr können damit
ganz schön viel machen wir haben unter
dem rost so w förmige flavours die hitze
gleichmäßig verteilen ich hab's gesehen
die bratwürste waren schön gleichmäßig
braun so das ist ein feature ihr könnt
damit auch auf jeden fall obwohl es geht
schon ab drin obwohl das ganze nicht
riesig ist nicht allzu viel platz
wegnimmt kann man damit lockt die sie
zehn personen begrenzt so wie ich auch
heute beinahe mache was sehr sehr cool
ist dass bernhard hat erstmalig und wer
weiß vielleicht auch einmalig 1 20%
rabatt code für euch oder für mich oder
wie auch immer rausgehauen nämlich max
20 relativ einfach den link unten in die
beschreibung ich bin wirklich sehr sehr
happy ich freue mich auf viele grill
videos mit diesem schönen gerät hier
noch und man muss auch dazu sagen
preislich gesehen ist das auch absolut
fair und ein code ist auch nicht nur für
grills anwendbar ihr könnt auch
pizzaöfen smoker zubehör alles möglich
ziehen deshalb vielen lieben dank ein
berner fürs unterstützen dieses kanals
ist macht es großen spaß damit zu gehen
und deshalb mache ich jetzt genau damit
weiter dass uns ein kleines steak fertig
machen muss irgendwas sagen natürlich
glaube nicht also das ist einfach ein
kunst werden von einem snack hier drüben
haben wir war auch eines das nicht zu
vernachlässigen ist also wie gesagt ich
habe keinen scheiß gekauft das ist
trotzdem ein bios der ecke liegen hier
bei 9 euro und hier drüben bei 100 euro
für ein steak dementsprechend sollte auf
jeden fall ein deutlicher unterschied
schmeckt wenn nicht wenn ich mir relativ
sicher wie mein urteil ausfällt als
erwartet fiel ich sage sowie weil es hat
auch seinen preis gekostet wir starten
mit dem günstigen schönes gesehen durch
das fed auge perfekt in der mitte und ab
auf dieser saison
beste zeit zu sein
[Musik]
so ist das
als wuchs erst einmal selber klar
gekommen also ich habe in meinem leben
23 mal vage zubereitet und jedes mal
wenn ich es mache bin ich so ganz
aufgeregt ich bin so wirkt so
ehrfürchtig das ist schon was besonderes
wie sie diese wunderbare marmorierung
der klassiker wie trotzdem super gut aus
ich würde sagen das schneiden das ganze
einmal die schöne tranchen auf wir haben
es wunderbar medium rare in der mitte
ich bin mir relativ sicher das wird kein
leichtes weil das wird trotzdem ein
unfassbar leckeres steak sein
so muss es sein wirklich bari muss man
minimum medium rare ist und dass hier
das wirklich einen korn dreschen aber
die frage ist wie wirkt sich das
geschmacklich aus was ist uns
herausfinden wir haben unsere tester
wieder da und ich sage euch so viel für
diesen moment wird es sich gelohnt haben
dass ihr gekommen seid ja und zwei
wunderbare stakes vielleicht ein
wunderbarer als das andere wir werden zu
erfahren seid so nett damit ihm wirklich
den unterschied merkt macht aber die
augen zu haben sich aber nur augen zu
machen ich gebe euch was streckt beide
meine hand aus
[Musik]
und geht los wir probieren das ganze auf
3 1 1 1
[Musik]
während die augen wieder aufmachen ich
habe das andere mal kurz weg gelegt was
sagt ihr also wirklich keine so dieser
grill flavour ist da die rasterung sagt
ich nichts weiter sagen
ihr müsst mich jetzt nicht festlegen
müssen die augen zumachen denn die ihre
gegenwart
[Musik]
das ist ganz klar
die ja ja die kita umgebung wie krippen
aus und es kommt immer mehr immer neuer
immer mehr geschmack bei dem 90 ps drauf
nach dem dritten bist du das so weil
aber das ist sowieso ein schwamm den
5000 mal ausquatschen kannst du bei
jedem mal drauf kommen nach moskau sowie
jungs was ist das denn man muss da jetzt
auch mal werden sagen sehr sehr gut geht
dann sehr schön an der seite von der
bratwurst
wir müssen nicht überreden will ich es
besser ist wenn ich aber dass keine
frage vergesst dabei nicht dass das eine
zehnmal teurer ist 100 eur 9 europa da
würde ich auch sagen ich finde trotzdem
hatten sich lob aber ist natürlich eine
sehr große preisspanne das hier werde
ich als erstes das habe ich jetzt sagt
aber auch das reicht nicht das leicht
ein schön und sagt man auch für den pilz
abend das waren mit dem auch der verkauf
gestellt wunderbaren griff play war so
schön karamellisiert an der größte aber
wenn du das halt im vergleich ist so für
besondere tage besonderen moment wenn du
wirklich so musst du hast du die
schwiegermutter davis überraschend an
dass da ist auf jeden fall die martina
damit er oberst duale herzen aber ist
wirklich immer wieder interessant finde
ich so eine gegenüberstellung haben bei
preiskomponente ist auch nicht zu
vernachlässigen bei der nächsten sache
liegt ihr ein bisschen weniger weit
auseinander und wenn man auf sich wenn
ich sage dass das ganze nicht so weit
auseinander ist es trotzdem noch ein
eindeutiger unterschied zu merken wir
haben hier ein schweine nackensteak der
absolute klassiker unter den deutschen
grill waren fertig marinierte dieses
hier kostet drei euro fünfzig und dass
wir ziemlich genau was wo bitte liegt
bei 7 eur 10 wir haben im gewicht
wahrscheinlich ziemlich nur das gleiche
das jetzt ein bisschen dicker ich mache
hier eine schnelle nicht marinade
sondern schnell lack fertig zur
abgesoffen oder es macht auf jeden fall
rein visuellen großen unterschied wie es
geschmacklich aussieht wenn wir gleich
sehen und mache erstmal den grill auf
der ball hat schön diesmal arbeiten
wieder mal nicht mit der single born und
ab jetzt
sehr gespannt
wie soll ein ganz eindeutiger
unterschied wir sehen auch so die dieses
schafft alles zusammenzuhalten bei der
luxusvariante beim klassiker gewohntes
bild aber beide sehen wirklich sehr gut
aus die nächste kreation diesmal dürft
ihr mit offenen augen verlieren dürfen
alle sinne mitnehmen hatte schon
vermutung dass ich
weiß
wir probieren den klassiker zuerst und
nochmal so die erinnerung quasi
aufzufrischen sieht der rein optisch
auch schon ein bisschen weniger saftiger
muss man schon sagen muss man muss man
wirklich sagen wir probieren es
das erinnert mich an so eine familie im
griff hat und früher ganz genau der
grill klassiker so du bist irgendwo zum
grillen eingeladen so im hintergrund
läuft deutsche nationalhymne 2014
haben wir zur alternative sprechen hier
von 3 50 und hier von 7 gesehen also im
vergleich zum steak grad eben deutlich
kleiner aus unterschiedlichen gerne
[Musik]
hier kann man aber direkt sagen der
preisunterschied ist deutlich geringer
aber ich finde der konsistenz deutlich
größer als riesen oder der fast ein ganz
anderes stück fleisch es könnte ein
anderer ist könnte das angst hier sein
wird ich komme dass sie auf dem grill
man kennt gar nicht so den qualitativen
unterschieden und wirklich bei dem
preisunterschied was schmeckt schon fast
fruchtig ja von einer ganzen verein
brennt also das ist mit abstand der
eindeutigste entscheidung wir sind ein
trend schließen einstellungen für das ja
eine sache haben wir noch das und das
große finale wir haben hier ein schweine
auf einmal mariniert aus der packung so
wie man es kennt und einmal puristisch
aber in bester qualität das ist nicht in
die ricoh sondern büro also man es gibt
bei kühen gibt es die kurve rinder gibt
da juli bei schweinen gibt es ibérico
und die rock also es sind sehr sehr edle
sehr sehr gut marmoriert besonderes
stück luxus stück für stück wie du sagst
aber ich muss weil das noch sehr
naturbelassen ist mit ein bisschen sei
es noch mal ran gehen dann können wir
auch schon auflegen zum 30 unterschied
wir haben hier so zwei euro irgendwas in
den drei gegen das ganze schon mal auf
und hier drüben fünf euro
so gehen wir das ganze einmal kräftig an
auch hier dass es uns mehr fett als
fleisch eigentlich so das kann richtig
heiß richtig angefühlt haben genau das
macht wird
[Musik]
hier haben wir die luxusversion okay die
herrschaft ich sage ganz ehrlich
vorgestern ein persönlicher koch gestern
durch köln heute gegrillt werden es lebt
sich schönen können jetzt auf jeden fall
willkommen hier haben sehr viel spaß mit
euch schon gehabt aber wir werden häufig
auch jetzt wieder sehr viel spaß haben
könnt euch eine gabel wir probieren
mir am grill schmecken nicht alles das
ist hier ohne aber
wirklich
hat nichts heute war nicht lecker das
stimmt die jungs haben mich wirklich
noch mal darauf aufmerksam gemacht wie
viel englisch ich eigentlich wäre ich
probiere mich auf den rest des videos
ein bisschen zusammenzureißen und
greifen wir zum luxusprodukt die rock
schweinebauch dass sie schmecken
interessant so jetzt können wir aber
nochmal auf diese wurzeln zurück kommen
verkackt hatte aber das hier geht auch
in die richtung das ist er ist und muss
ich jetzt ich sage das ist ehrlich hätte
mich gefragt oder dass ich wüsste hätte
ich gesagt das von der konsistenz ist
qualitativ hochwertigen und gleichzeitig
alle einige und wie ich bin auch wie es
geht ich hatte im leben als auch nicht
mag sind diese stellen ist ein bisschen
trocken ja in jedem fall bin ich
vollkommen bei so einem einfachen dummen
leckeren stück die bauchspeck ist das
hier absolut das dass wir zwei
rohstoffen worden das war genau gleich
geschnitten oder werk liegender 12
punkte in der zubereitung aber auch beim
ersten probieren ohne das andere
überhaupt gegessen schon wird schwer das
zu toppen da das richtig trägt ja jungs
ich danke euch sehr schön dass ihr dabei
war ich auch ihr habt wirklich mit
erkenntnis trainiert sehr viel spaß
macht schön dass ich dabei werde dank
noch mal an bernhard dass sie
unterstützt haben und wir sehen uns
wieder bis dahin nachts guten job auch
bei jungs vorbei schaut übrigens auf